All right, welcome everybody to another Zoom call.
We are people coming in here.
So hold on.
And then we'll get started.
Mr. Another reminder, if you're searching for things
between Zoom calls, put our website and look at the search
bar.
Always look at the member site, the homepage,
whether it's a big what's new site, what's new.
Imagine this last week is the courses.
All of our courses are free for all of our full patients.
So there's really nothing new with the stop fighting cancer
course for you because I give that to you guys on the membership
site.
Seven phases of detox, it gets valuable.
Somebody that family member with Lyme, that's valuable,
that course, frequency healing course,
is everything you want to know about the right.
So, and then we will have a couple other courses here,
mushroom course, and our course on genetics that should be
done actually this week, the genetics course will be up.
And then we'll have a lot of review of course as well.
So feel free to nerd out on some stuff there if that helps you.
All right, let's jump into the questions first.
There's a question I'll take this question off of the chat.
First, can you think of any reason a person who has no thyroid
and takes synthetic thyroid medication should be careful of
logos.
So, logo solution is an iodine solution.
And yes, anybody can overdose on iodine.
You've got to be careful of that.
But if you have no thyroid, because the thyroid is removed,
there still is a need for iodine, iodine.
The first thing you think of for iodine is the need for a thyroid,
because it's part in parcel of how you make thyroid hormone
is iodine.
But still, there's other needs in the body for iodine,
and they can certainly take glucose or other iodine supplement.
But what's the right way to use the right for neuropathy,
specifically using the mat, or how often, et cetera?
So I think there are some neuropathy bulb programs.
And you could use that.
But really, the best way to use right for neuropathy
is running the detoxification programs on the foot bath.
The clear detox programs on the foot bath
are much more appropriate for neuropathy,
especially if it's chemotherapy-induced neuropathy.
So chemotherapy is a hard chemical damage
as the neurons, especially the peripheral neurons.
And that's what neuropathy is.
So using the iodine flow wave in the clear detox program
is the best thing for neuropathy, as far as use with the right.
We also have some other tools for neuropathy.
One is the rebuilder.
The rebuilder is FDA-approved neuropathy machine.
So it stimulates the nerves at their specific frequency,
using an electrical frequency device
and it could be good for neuropathy to help you rebuild the nerves.
It works quite well too.
That's on our store if you're interested.
All right, I have bone metastasis for my breast cancer.
Is there a way to gauge the health of my bones on your end?
We need it from a natural perspective.
I have a traditional, I have traditional bone scans,
but it's difficult to interpret if it's scar tissue
or it's lesions.
Overall, I feel good and I would love to run again,
but whatever I bring this up to my ecologist,
she strongly urges me to reconsider.
So I don't want to live in fear,
but I also don't want to be stranded on a path
with a broken leg or hip, any thoughts.
So with the deal with bone metastasis and cancer,
even if you don't have bone metastasis and cancer,
you do have to be careful of exercises
that are going to be pounding on your bones,
that are going to be hard on your bones, your joints.
You just have to be careful of that,
even if you have no history of bone metastasis.
With the history of bone metastasis,
I would fall on the side of your oncologist there
because you just don't know if there's any weakness.
There's no way to tell if there's any weakness
in certain joints.
And certainly the femoral neck, which
is the little angle of the femur that
is attached to the estabulum of the pelvic joint
is a very day.
That's where people get their hips replaced.
That's what they're getting replaced.
That will join there.
That you do not want to have a bone met fracture.
Now, even if the cancer was in your ribs,
you still have to just be conscious of that.
Now there's ways to go running without actually running.
You could go racewalking, or you're kind of more
at a shuffle.
Racewalking is actually much better for your body,
and you're getting across crawl mechanism,
going, you could take up bike heat or something else.
But I would agree that you don't want pounding exercise
that's going to be pounding on your bones,
especially as you age.
It's just hard on your bones, even if you don't have cancer at all.
Secondly, the first part of this question
was to, because there any way to gauge
the health of the bones without doing a CT scan
or a bone scan or a dexter scan, which
measures osteoporosis and bone density,
no, there really isn't any way from a national perspective.
There isn't any necessarily blood tests or anything
to measure that other than doing a scan.
I'll just go ahead.
I'm wondering about updates for frequencies.
Do we do this?
And how often?
So there's value in updating your frequencies
from true right, but a fairly regular basis
if you're running other programs on the right,
other than your program.
So if you're the kind of person, like all I
run is the programs that Dr. Connor
has made for me, whether there is never a reason
to update the frequencies on your right, never.
But if you're the kind of person that is like,
oh my gosh, I run the other frequencies all the time
if I have another issue or somebody in the family
has found an issue there running other programs
on the right all the time.
Well, then there's value in updating the frequencies.
I would do it more than once every month or two realistically.
If you don't run that many programs
other than your programs, maybe every three to six months,
because like a trip is an updating and that frequently.
So if you do update the frequencies on your right,
if you have to put on our website and you could click go right
there and click on that and type in the search updating frequencies
and we give you a tutorial on how to do that.
It's quite simple.
All you do is got to connect your computer to your Wi-Fi
in your house, you got to get it connected to internet
and then all you do is on the right, go up
to the right hand side, open up any right program,
go up to the right hand side and says update frequencies,
click on that and it'll start downloading an update.
So, but prior, you know, so like I update my frequencies
about every three to six months at our house,
but we have some patients that never updated their frequencies
in five years because they don't run any other programs.
So then there's really no need to.
Always, if you're going to do the update,
make sure you put your computer back on airplane modes
so that you take it off of Wi-Fi again.
So that's the number one computer problem
is having your computer connected to the internet
because they don't try to download
and resilient things that you don't want.
Recently, you discussed that via your protocols
or other methods, tumor growth can be stopped
and therefore no longer fits the definition of cancer.
You also mentioned that unless there's a pressing
medical reason a person could often just live
with no longer a cancerous tumor.
I was wondering if you could address
how once the tumor no longer fits the definition
of cancer, one can still reduce the size
of the tumor or completely eliminate
the tumor through no surgical methods.
Any particular successful case studies
that is colon cancer that you are liberty
to discuss would be helpful too.
So yes, I said that if a cancer stops growing,
so let's say you have a mass in your colon,
it's three centimeters round, let's say.
And then three months later, it's 4.5 centimeters round
and let's say you start chemotherapy
and then you measure it again, three months later
and it's 4.5 centimeters round.
Well, three months, it didn't grow at all.
That's a good thing, right?
And you do chemo and you're still doing chemo,
let's say and you're doing natural care too
and three months later, it's still 4.5 centimeters.
And then they're saying, well, it's stabilized,
typically this is what they'd say,
it's a bit of a where the cancer is,
it's stabilized now, it's time to do surgery
and remove this tumor.
Question is, is there any way to remove the tumor somehow
dissipate the tumor without doing surgery?
Well, you're always too trying to do those things.
You're using right frequencies
to get your immune system to kill it
and to destroy it.
Problem is, sometimes your body walls it off,
the fibrous sheath so that you can't get at it at all.
That's very common with lung cancers
and it's common in breast cancers as well.
It's common in brain cancers too.
So there's nothing you can do but surgical removal
if you do want to have it removed.
And it's time that that's when it can be appropriate.
If the surgeon has confidence that they can go in there
and basically get it all or most of it
without having to dissect the tumor itself
and break it up and cause possible spread by doing that,
that's the time to do surgery.
So I don't have any success stories of,
I can't think of anything off my head
of any anecdotal stories of the person,
what he was pressed to do surgery
and then did some natural approach in the tumor shrunk.
We've had plenty of patients where the tumor did shrink
and was gone and wasn't able to be filed afterwards.
But that wasn't how the question started
is that it gets to the point where it's no longer
the definition of cancer and it's because it's not growing.
It's staying at that same size for experience of months.
Therefore it's not continuing to rapidly replicate
is there a way to diminish the size?
Well, in truth, if the patient is our patient,
we're doing everything we possibly can from a natural perspective
to diminish the size.
We're not trying to just stop it from growing.
We're trying to get rid of this thing.
But if the final solution is that it just stops growing
all my comments was, hey, if that's good enough,
it's not blocking the lumen of your colon,
or if it's not blocking, you're pressing on
your bile duct or an artery or something,
you're better sometimes just letting
sleeping giants lie.
But if there is a need for removal,
it's blocking a percentage of the lumen of the colon
or it's putting pressure on an artery
and the person's having 18 spells or something
and surgery is probably the best option.
Looking at the gursum diet for recipes,
and they promote only using flax oil
and not coconut oil.
Do you have any thoughts on this?
Well, there's nothing wrong with cold pressed flax oil.
But I don't think there's anything wrong with coconut oil.
So, remember all the gursum diet and all of gursum stuff,
my biggest pet peeve about that,
is that Max Gerson put this together in the 1930s and the 1940s,
when a lot of other things weren't even available.
Coconut oil was not readily available
in the continental United States at that time.
So, he didn't speak about coconut oil really at all.
He had a lot of different thoughts about different nutrients
nutrients that if I'm convinced that he was alive today,
he would have changed his tutor a lot of things
because more information came out, more studies came out.
Remember, at that time, there was literally almost no studies
on nutritional and nutritional suitable.
Everything was anecdotal and shared in a more difficult way.
There was no internet, of course.
So, if he was alive today,
I'm convinced he would make a lot of different changes
to his poll call.
So, I don't think there's anything wrong
with using coconut oil.
Still struggling, especially at night with a cough
from the aspergillus in the right lung.
I've nebulized those used of tincture,
different essential oils used, applied to the feed chest,
and abused any other suggestions.
Well, the best way to kill something in your lung
when it's a fungus in your lung,
like aspergillus is through a nebulizer,
trying different substances in the nebulizer would be my choice.
I would try different anti-fungal type nutrients
that are liquid, that I'd put in the nebulizer
using different concentrations and play with that.
I still think nebulizing is gonna be the best way
to get that out of there.
I will say that if I'm pretty sure this person
is doing this, but cortiseps is a mushroom
that is really essential for healing the lungs.
Make sure you up the cortiseps.
If you're taking cortiseps, make sure you bump that up as well.
I think we have cortiseps mixed with some other
herbs in a liquid that you could nebulize that.
Now that I think of it, that might be a good choice too.
I think it's a herbal,
through herbal dropper, lung dropper by close defense
that has cortiseps in it.
I would try that once when I would give that a try as well.
Questions from the chat.
The elbow adapter on the power cord
or the cutter's put a computer is loose
and the power connection disconnects daily.
I do not move my computer, kind of frustrated.
Oh, so it's the power cord itself.
Please just give the clinic a call
and I'm pretty sure we have some extra power cords
so we can send you and see if there's something with that.
I don't know what the elbow connector is,
but it might be just something loose
or is it the one that connects right into the computer
and it's loose?
That's frustrating.
Maybe a new one would fit better.
So, yes, maybe a new one would fit better.
We can certainly send you another one.
Using oxymeter by blood oxygenation is sometimes 98 to 99.
If you are as I do 95 to 96, what is the reason?
The little oxymeters are not the most accurate
in the world and most likely it's just its connection
to your hand.
If you're over 93, 94, you're doing great
where you're concerned as you're regularly dealt with the 80s.
So your numbers are just fine.
Dairy is a cancer driver for me,
but ghee is okay in my binder.
Am I overthinking this?
Is this okay to use?
Yes, I say that's okay to use.
Plus, how much ghee are you consuming?
Can't consume very much ghee of us.
You really have to make an effort to
so you're just fine with ghee.
What types of mushrooms are in the miracle mushroom mix?
That's our blend.
Off the top of my head, we have Rishi,
we have Cordiceps, I'm pretty sure.
We have Myataki.
And then there's, we call it the miracle mushroom,
expect there's Moringa,
there's some other immune stimulants in there too.
Whether to look, it's on the store,
sites, the list of things that are good there.
There are a lot of organic foods
where all the ingredients are good,
except it has sunflower or safflower oil in it.
These are not on my approved oil list.
Are they that bad or should all products
with sunflower, safflower oil be avoided?
Well, there's an argument with that.
You know, most sunflower and safflower oils
that you buy, let's see,
if you just bought a crisp of sunflower oil,
it is not a good oil to be using.
So if you're using something you're cooking,
you should only be using olive oil or coconut oil,
sunflower oil, safflower oil, and cord oil
is just not a good oil to be using whatsoever.
However, in some organic products,
there is organic cold pressed sunflower oil
and organic cold pressed safflower oil.
Those are not necessarily bad oils.
They're not necessarily something you should avoid.
They can be a good organic cold pressed sunflower or safflower oil
can actually be appear into oil.
So if it's just in a product they're using,
and it's organic, I would not say
you have to worry about staying away from that.
Can you repeat slide number one about the thyroid?
What we were talking about
is a question about the thyroid gland.
Somebody asked a question on the chat
about can somebody with no thyroid
that takes synthetic synthroid,
should they be careful about lougals,
which is an iodine, and I said no,
they could certainly still take iodine.
There's other needs for a iodine.
Don't show your question that you're asking about the thyroid.
I want to get ahead of you with a thyroid question here.
So if you can think of what you're asking,
folks to share.
I'm doing sauna, castor oil pack, daily coffee,
animals, is there still a value in doing calonics?
My answer to that is only occasionally.
So the value in doing calonics,
so a calonic is you put it up to farther up your colon
to flush it out.
I see the value of doing calonics.
The person is very bad,
very, very bad constipation that can't get released.
That's where a calonic is in.
You have to be careful with calonics
because you can't flush out your microbiota with calonics.
So I'm not a fan of doing regular calonics for that purpose.
You're already doing soda, castor oil pack,
daily coffee, animals.
I'd say no to the calonics,
unless you have serious constipation issues.
Are you familiar with the Tahibault T pure Pada Arco T?
That, particularly that product,
but I am very familiar with Pada Arco.
It can be a great cancer killer.
It can be a good Lyme disease killer.
Pada Arco is a good product
and I don't see anything wrong with using it as a T
if you're using it as a T,
or even as a nutritional supplement,
there's nothing wrong with using Pada Arco.
So Christine, did you get your thyroid question back?
Is this the slide you want to be
to go over bolimus testysis?
We'll email it.
I'll have to call you on that
because I did not get your email.
Sorry.
Why didn't look at the email unless you just email.
Sorry, I missed it.
I should, I use the gray mat with the regular
right wand and the neuropathy setting.
So the mat is, so you should use the ion pro-way.
So you're doing the ion pro-way,
not the regular right wand, not the bulb.
So this person's talking about neuropathy again.
So if you have neuropathy, you want to run the ion pro-way program.
That's the foot bath programming.
Yes, you do use the brownie mat with the ion pro-way.
So go back to your ion pro-way that's instructions.
If you've not used ion pro-way for a few,
you're not used to it, then remember,
go back to the, use the membership site.
Remember I added about 25 videos on the membership site
under the right, so if you're having any right issues,
at all, go to the membership site
and look at the right tab.
You can see it's like a guide to your email here quick.
You can see it here.
You can send that again.
I'll get back to you on that person.
All right, these are your short.
You guys don't call up with some more questions.
Maybe you'll email that to Ann.
Sorry.
And I have not done any other research on the TCMAM stuff.
I apologize.
I'm working on a number of other videos and things.
So I will get at that.
So have you heard of high dose melatonin for cancer?
Like two hundred and ten million years?
Yes.
And I'll be right about that in the stock fighting cancer book.
And it can be beneficial.
So yes, it's.
You don't necessarily have to.
Most of the writings don't say that necessarily go up to 210 milligrams.
It's anywhere between 60 milligrams and maybe 200 milligrams.
But most people are doing high dose melatonin might be doing like 80 to 100 milligrams.
That's the average.
We do have a 20 milligram melatonin capsule in our store.
It's hard to find the high dose melatonin capsules.
It's not very expensive.
It's something that some people have added.
Doesn't test very well typically of people who don't have a lot of people on that.
Can I eat organic popcorn?
I'm trying to remember this person's.
Two drivers.
I'm sure you're fine with organic popcorn.
That's just all about moderation.
So yes.
I want to.
Everybody should understand when you're talking about diet and what's driving your cancer and what you can't.
You want to keep in mind the fact that.
You know, we're testing for rethink or is driving your cancer and let's say we take you off of dairy.
It's the most common thing that we take people off.
So use that as an example.
So.
It doesn't mean that other foods don't cause inflammation go cause it inflammatory process.
Just because you have a diagnosis of cancer doesn't mean you also don't have.
Some sort of hidden on a immune disease.
It doesn't mean you don't also some have.
Also have at the same time food sensitivities and antibodies to different peptides and different foods.
So you got to be aware of that too.
And while I'm trying to fight this cancer and I don't want to be on a really super restrictive diet for other things too.
No, but let's say let's say use a simplest example.
Let's say you're you're often dairy for your cancer and that's hard thing to stay off of.
But let's say you have antibodies to gliann and gluten peptides.
So gliann is the protein in.
In gluten and there are a number of different peptides in gluten portions of that protein molecule that you can your body can create antibodies against.
And now you have circulated antibodies against gluten or the peptides of gluten.
So every time you eat gluten, even though you're you're trying to do your best to take care of your cancer, but every time you eat your causing this inflammatory reaction.
And this inflammatory reaction is is going to dampen a more specific immune reaction to your cancer.
So you do have to be cognitant of the fact that if you are doing other things that are is causing ramped up systemic inflammation in your body.
You know, exposing yourself to GMO foods and you know exposing yourself to toxins in your environment that you could stay away from like boy don't spray in your lawn with chemicals and doing these things.
You are exposing yourself to things that is ramping up inflammation from the systemic point of view to your body that's going to hinder an immune response against a specific.
The thing like cancer so you're hindering your body's ability to kill cancer when you're causing inflammation from some other.
From some other source that you could mitigate if you took the steps to do so so there's we have patients that to do a food sensitivity panel from us that are cancer patients because they they understand that and they want to.
Decrease overall systemic inflammation so their body can concentrate on their immune system can concentrate on killing the cancer instead of going after all these things that are just going to cause problems in their body.
And it's just causing wrapped up inflammation elsewhere and doing much worse things causing damage to different organs if you have antibodies self antibodies to your thyroid then making somebody made a comment about their thyroid it's quite possible that a number of people on this call right now have Hashimoto's also that means you have antibodies to your thyroid so you should be stayed away from anything that's going to cause a ramped up inflammation so.
Getting a Syrex panel done which is the best food sensitivity panel because it measures the different peptides in foods measures whether the food is cooked whether food is raw that is the most sensitive the best panel to run a Syrex 10 Syrex 2 or 3x and 4 measures gluten and gluten cross reactants in a Syrex 10 measures hope on each other food.
It's valuable panels to know so that you know your body's not trying to fight the war at multiple fronts and your immune system can concentrate on trying to kill the cancer instead of being disturbed by auto antibody responses.
It's something to think about so the reason why that fire that in my mind is because the question about eating popcorn so yes you can eat organic popcorn so as long as you don't have any food sensitivity of corn which is common foods that's typical so just because something's not driving you cancer doesn't mean that's a certain good food so not saying organic popcorn is bad for you.
But if you had antibodies to corn then it would be bad for you so you can kind of know those things you can get some clues about that without going to test by by keeping a really strong journal that you know everything you eat and how you feel you know within a day after you ate that you can get some clues to whether that is a sensitivity or not.
But it's hard because typically don't just eat one thing in a given day so that you're able to test that you're in a multiple different food sources and you don't want to use that you're likely reacting to and secondly it's hard to test that from just a dietary standpoint because you don't always know if you got wrapped up systemic inflammation you don't always get symptoms from it.
You're just going to get a decrease to be a response to what you want to have a healthy food response to any other questions.
No, all right well we'll get this recording up tonight and make sure you stay on the membership site look at updates on there look at things that we add on there and
look at any announcements on there.
What are the long-term effects of Black Sabbath patients like me there are any negative one-term effects of Black Sabbath by wife did Black Sabbath I don't know about 10 years ago for the 10 years ago this.
No, no, no, no.
So all right how you get the free courses all the courses are free you log in.
Remember you just log in with the same log in you used to go on the membership site same log in you used to go on the membership site you log into the courses and you find the courses on the website you'll see if I've assessed courses all the courses should be able to click in and log into.
All right, bye. I prayed for all you guys. Love you all. See you next week.